If you're hungry,
it's not a deterministic drive fits a
some personality that has a goal and
then it has a bunch of action patterns
that are going to work in reference to
that goal.
It has a bunch of perceptions that that
suit that goal and it organizes your
emotional responses around that goal.
And so to think about it as a
personality is a much,
it's a much more intelligent way to look
at it.
One of the thing about skinner's rats,
you know,
skinner could get rats to do almost
everything and he would reward them with
food.
And so he had a simple model but his
rats were starved down to 75% of their
normal body weight.
So not only were they not social
gregarious routes like rats are cause
they were isolated,
they're genetically altered from wild
routes,
but they also weren't as complex as a
real route because they were starving.
And so,
but you know,
a starving rat is a pretty good model of
a rat.
And a rat has a pretty good model of a
person.
But are a lot of our models have simple
behavior learning were based on starving
isolated rats.
So anyways,
how to think about motivation.
We'll think about it from the
hypothalamic perspective.
So we could say one thing that
motivation does is set goals and we
could say that emotions track progress
towards goals and I'm going to use that
Schema even though it's not exactly
right.
So you say,
well motivation determines where you're
going to aim.
So if you're hungry you're going to name
it something to eat and then that will
organize your perceptions so that you
zero out everything that isn't relevant
to that task,
which is almost everything you
concentrate on those few things that are
going to facilitate your movement
forward.
When you encounter those things that
produces positive emotion,
as you move through the world towards
your goal and you see that things are
laying themselves out that facilitate
your movement forward,
those things cause positive emotion and
if you encounter anything that gets in
the way,
then that produces negative emotion and
it can be like threat because you're not
supposed to encounter something that
gets in the way.
It can be anger so that you move it
away.
It can be frustration,
disappointment,
grief.
Those would,
if,
if you had a response that serious to an
obstacle,
it would probably punish the little
motivated frame right out of existence.
You know,
so you walked downstairs and I dunno,
they're contracting company has had a
wrecking ball through your kitchen.
It's like that's going to be
disappointed.
You're not going to keep eating the
peanut butter sandwich and the rubble,
that little frame is going to get
punished out of existence and some new
goal is going to pop up and it's
instead,
and you know,
one of the things we're going to try to
sort out is how do you decide when
you've encountered an obstacle that's so
big that you should just quit and go do
something else?
Because that's not obvious.
You know,
and you can,
you can get into counterproductive
persistence pretty easily.
So we don't know how people solve that
problem.
It's a really complicated one.
So anyways,
we're going to work on that scenario.
Your hypothalamus pops up.
Micro goals that are directly relevant
to biological now produces a frame of
reference.
So it's not a goal.
It's not a drive and it's not a
collection of behaviors.
It's a little personality and the
personality has a viewpoint.
It has thoughts that go along with it.
It has perceptions,
it has action tendencies,
all of that.
You can see this in addiction most
particularly.
So one of the things that you find often
with people who are alcoholic is they
lie all the time.
And that's because when they're,
they built a little alcohol dependent
personality inside of themselves or a
big one,
it might,
maybe it's 90% of their personality.
And one of that,
one of the things that compose consists
of is all the rationalizations that
they've used over the years to justify
their addiction to themselves and to
other people.
And so the addiction has a personality,
you know,
and so when the person is off,
maybe they are addicted to meth or
something like that where we know the
addiction is more,
it's,
it's more short term powerful than I
would say,
than an alcohol addiction.
They'll say anything.
And the,
the,
the words are just tools used to get
towards the goal.
And if they happen to be deceptive,
whatever,
it doesn't matter.
They're just practical tools to get
towards the goal.
And then when you get towards the goal
and you take a nice shot of math or
something like that,
you reinforce all those rationales that
you use to get the drug and then the
next time you're even a better deceiver
and liar.
So,
okay,
so we're going to say motivations,
one way of thinking about as they set
goals,
but it's not the right way of thinking
about it.
They produce a whole framework of
interpretation.
And so we're going to think about that
framework of interpretation and then
emotions emerging side of that.
So that's a,
so the world is framed.
Motivations,
set goals.
You could say the world has to be
framed.
So motivation sets that frame,
crews,
goals,
emotions,
perceptions and actions and inactions
track progress.
So positive emotion says you're moving
forward properly towards your goal.
And if you encounter something you don't
expect,
you stop.
That's anxiety.
It's like,
oh,
we're not where we thought we were.
And so we don't know what to do.
So we should stop because we don't know
where we are,
what we're doing.
Stop frozen.
And then the more powerful negative
emotions like pain they might make you
get out of there.
So emotions forward,
stop,
reverse.
That's your emotions within that
motivated frame.
So,
and that's another example of how your
mind is embedded in your body.
Your emotions are like their,
their offshoots of action tendencies.
That's,
that's the right way to think about it.
Cause action has everything
fundamentally.
So what are some basic motivations?
Uh,
most of these are regulated by the
hypothalamus by the way.
And that,
that tells you just how important the
control system it is.
The other thing that's useful to know
about the hypothalamus is that it has
projections going up from it that are
like tree trunks and inhibitory
projections coming down there.
They're like grape vines.
So you can kind of control your
hypothalamus as long as it's not on too
much.
But if on in any serious way it's like
it,
it winds.
So partly what you do to stop yourself
from falling under the dominion of your
hypothalamus is to never ever be
anywhere where it's action is necessary,
right?
You don't want to go into a biker bar
because you might find yourself in a
situation where panicked.
Defensive aggression is immediately
necessary.
You probably don't want that.
You don't want the panic,
you don't want the terror,
you don't want the frenzied fight,
you don't want any of that.
You don't want to have to run away in
absolute panic.
So you just don't go there.
And then a huge,
a huge part of how we regulate our
emotions is just by never going anywhere
where we have to experience them.
And so that has very little to do with
internal inhibitory control and
everything to do with staying where you
belong.
So,
okay,
so basic motivations,
hunger,
thirst,
pain,
pain is not regulated by the
hypothalamus.
That's a different circuit.
Anger slash aggression,
thermoregulation panic and escape,
affiliation and care,
sexual desire,
exploration play.
And you can kind of break those in.
You can kind of break those into the
classic Darwinian categories too and
say,
well there's a set of motivations that
go along with self maintenance.
That'd be your survival ingestive and
defensive.
See I've sort of coded them there.
So the,
the self maintenance,
there's an adjustive set of basic
motivations that go with self
maintenance.
You'd say that's hunger thirst,
there's a set of defensive motivations,
pain,
anger,
thermal regulation,
paddock and escape.
And then there's,
there's motivations that are associated
with reproduction,
affiliation care and sexual desire.
And then I put exploration in play sort
of outside of that.
Uh,
well I would say because those two
things serve both of these approximately
equally.
When I went to Harvard,
I came from the Gill and I had spent a
lot of time with my advisor there and,
and a research team that he had trying
to understand the genesis of antisocial
behavior and
among adolescents mostly so well as kids
as well.
Anti social behavior is very persistent.
So if you have a child whose conduct
disordered at the age of four,
the probability that they will be
criminal at the age of 15 or 20 is
extremely high.
It's unbelievably stable.
It's a very dismal literature because
you see these early onset aggressive
kids and and it's persistent and then
you look at the intervention literature
and you throw up your hands because no
interventions work.
And believe me,
psychologists have tried everything you
could possibly imagine and a bunch of
things that you can't in order to
ameliorate that.
So we are really interested in trying to
understand,
for example,
if you're antisocial by age of four,
then there isn't an intervention that
seems to be effective.
So,
and the,
the standard peanut logical theory is
really quite horrifying in this regard
because what you see is that male
aggression peaks around the age of 15
and then it declines fairly
precipitously and,
and,
and sort of re normalizes again by the
age of 27 and standard peanut logical
theory essentially is this cold hearted.
It's like if you have a multi,
if you have someone who's a multiple
offender,
you just throw him in prison til they're
27 and then the age out of it.
And that's all there is to it.
That's,
that's what we've got.
Now.
There's some downside to that because
there's a corollary literature that
suggests that the worst thing that you
can do with antisocial people is to
group them together,
which is what we do in prisons.
So that's a whole mess.
Anyways,
one of the things we were doing was
trying to see if there might be
cognitive predictors of antisocial
behavior.
And so we use this battery of
neuropsychological tests that was put
together at the Montreal neurological
institute.
Took about 11 hours to administer and
hypothetically assess prefrontal
cortical function and we computerized
out and reduced it to about 90 minutes
and then,
um,
assessed antisocial adolescents in,
in Montreal and found out that they did
show deficits in,
in problem solving ability that we were
associated with,
uh,
with prefrontal ability.
Um,
when I got to Harvard,
I thought,
well,
that's interesting.
We could use the neuro psych battery to
predict negative behavior.
Perhaps we could use it to predict
positive behavior.
So I thought,
well,
what if we turn the neuro psych battery
and over and thought,
well,
can we predict grades for example?
Cause you know,
that's a decent thing to predict.
So we ran a study,
we ran a study that looked at Harvard
kids,
University of Toronto kids,
line workers at a Milwaukee factory and
managers and executives at the same
factory.
And what we found was that the average
score across these neuropsychological
tests,
they were kind of like games.
They were game like,
you know.
So in one,
in one test you had,
there were five lights in the middle of
the screen and a box was associated with
each light and you had to learn by trial
and error,
which box was associated with,
with each light.
That was one of the tests.
Um,
so we took people's average score across
the tests because they seem to clump
together into a single structure.
You can do it,
you can find that out.
Statistically,
if you take a bunch of tests,
you can find out how they clump together
statistically by looking at their
patterns of correlations.
And you might get multiple clumps,
which is what happens with personality
research where you get five or you might
get a singular clump,
which is what happens in cognitive
research.
And we got a single clump essentially.
And then we were trying to figure out if
at the same time I was reading the
literature on performance prediction and
there's an extensive literature on
performance prediction.
A lot of it generated by the armed
forces,
by the way,
um,
indicating Iq is a very good predictor
of longterm life success.
And so here's the,
here's the general rule.
If your job is simple,
which means you do the same thing every
day,
then Iq predicts how fast you'll learn
the job,
but not how well you you do it.
But if your job is complex,
which means that the demands change on
an ongoing basis,
then the best predictor of success is
general cognitive ability.
And,
uh,
and I learned that the general cognitive
ability tests clump together into a
single factor that's fluid intelligence
or,
or Iq.
And then we didn't know if the factor
that we had found was the same factor as
Iq and it,
and we still haven't really figured out
whether or not that was the case because
it kind of depends on how you do the
analysis.
But anyway,
so I got deeply into the performance
prediction literature and I found out,
well,
if you want it to predict people's
performance in life,
there's,
there's a couple of things you need to
know.
You need to know their general cognitive
ability.
If they're going to do a complex job,
you need to know their trait
conscientiousness.
Some of you might've heard that
rebranded as grit in a very corrupt act
by the way,
because it's a good predictor of
longterm life success,
freedom from negative emotion.
Low neuroticism is another predictor,
but it's sort of third on the hierarchy.
And then openness to experience,
which is a personality trait,
is associated with,
with expertise in creative domains.
The evidence that now I should tell you
it's such a complicated question.
I should tell you how to make an Iq test
because they're actually really easy.
And you need to know this to actually
understand what Iq is.
So imagine that you generated a a set of
10,000 questions.
Okay?
About anything.
It could be math problems,
they could be general knowledge,
they could be vocabulary,
they could be multiple choice.
It really doesn't matter what they're
about as long as they require
abstraction to solve.
So they'd be formulated linguistically,
but mathematically would also apply.
And then you have those 10,000
questions.
Now you take a random set of a hundred
of those questions and you give them to
a thousand people and all you do is sum
up the answers right from.
So some people are going to get most of
them right and some of some of them are
going to get most of them wrong.
You just rank ordered the people in
terms of their score,
correct that for age and you have Iq.
That's all there is to it.
And what you'll find is that no matter
which random set of 100 questions you
take,
the people at the top of one random set
will be at the top of all the others.
And,
and with very,
very,
very high consistency.
So one thing you need to know is that if
any social science claims whatsoever are
correct,
then the Iq claims are correct because
the Iq claims are more psychometrically
rigorous than any other phenomena
phenomenon that's been discovered by
social scientists.
Now the ICU literature is a dismal
literature.
No one likes it.
Here's why.
Here's an example.
So here's our little,
here's a fun little fact for you,
for Liberals and conservatives alike,
because conservatives think there's a
job for everyone.
If people just get off their asses and
get to work and liberals think while you
can train anyone to do anything,
it's like,
no,
there isn't a job for everyone and no,
you can't train everyone to do
everything that's wrong.
And here's one of the consequences of
that.
So as I mentioned,
the Armed Forces has done a lot of work
on Iq and they started back in 1919 and
the reason they did that was because,
well,
for obvious reasons,
say let's say there's a war and you want
to get qualified people into the officer
positions as rapidly as possible or
you'll lose.
So that's a reason.
Now,
the armed forces has experimented with
Iq tests since 1919 and in the last 20
years I'm a law was passed as a
consequence of that analysis,
which was that it was illegal to induct
anyone into the armed forces who had an
Iq of less than 83 now,
the question is why?
And the answer was all of that effort
put in by the armed forces indicated
that if you had an Iq of 83 or less,
there wasn't anything that you could be
trained to do in the military that
wasn't positively counterproductive.
Now you gotta think about that a,
because the military is chronically
desperate for people,
right?
There's not like they're,
it's not like people are lining up to be
inducted,
right?
They have to go out and recruit.
And it's not easy.
And so they're desperate to get their
hands on every body they can possibly
manage.
And then,
especially in wartime,
but also in peacetime.
But then there was another reason too,
which was the armed forces,
was also set up from a policy
perspective to take people in the
underclass,
let's say,
and train them and moved them up at
least into the working class or maybe
the middleclass.
So there's a policy element to it too.
And so even from that perspective,
you could see that the military is
desperate to bring people in.
But with an Iq of 83 or less,
it's not happening.
Okay,
so how many people have an Iq of 83 or
less?
10%
now,
if that doesn't,
if that doesn't hurt you to hear,
then you didn't hear it properly.
Because what it implies is that in a
complex society like ours and one that's
becoming increasingly complex,
there isn't anything for 10% of the
population to do.
All right,
well,
what are we going to do?
We're going to ignore that.
We're going to run away from that.
And believe me,
we have every reason to,
or we going to contend with the fact
that we need to figure out how it is,
how it is,
how it might be possible to find a place
for people on the lower end of the
general cognitive distribution to take
their productive and worthwhile place in
society.
And that isn't just going to be a matter
of dumping money down the hierarchy
because giving people who have nothing
to do money isn't helpful.
It doesn't work.
It's not that simple.
Well,
so that's kind of an answer to the
question of whether or not we should
deal with the,
with Iq forthrightly.
It's like
if you can find a flaw in that logic,
like just go right ahead.
It's not like I was thrilled to death to
discover all of this by knows by no
stretch of the imagination was that the
case.
So,
so what?
So Iq is reliable and valid.
That's the first thing.
It's more reliable and valid than any
other psychometric test ever designed by
social scientists by a factor of about
three.
That's fact number one.
Fact number two is it predicts longterm
life outcome at about 0.3 0.4 which
leaves about 85% 70 to 85% of the story
unexplained.
But it's still the best thing that we
have.
Well,
it's also the case that in places like
Great Britain,
when Iq tests were first introduced,
they were actually used by the
socialists and they were used to
identify poor people who had potential
cognitive potential and to move them
into higher into institutes of higher
education.
So there's an upside,
you know,
social upside as well.
This is something you can't say anything
about without,
without immediately being killed.
So I'm hesitant to broach the topic,
but I'll tell you one thing that I did
in the last week that's relevant to
this.
So the,
and this just shows you how complex the
problem is.
First of all,
we should point out that race is a very
difficult thing to define because racial
boundaries aren't tight,
right?
So,
and so when you talk about racial
differences in Iq,
you,
you're faced with a thorny problem of
defining race.
And that's a big problem from a
scientific perspective.
But we'll leave that aside.
And I wrote an article this week.
Somebody stood up at one point,
one of my talks and vice,
bless their hearts,
took this particular question and used
it as an indication of the quality of
the people who are my so called
followers.
And by the way,
the quality of my so called followers is
pretty damn high.
And you can find that out quite rapidly
just by going looking at the youtube
comments,
which are head and shoulders above what
the standard set of youtube comments.
I can tell you that.
So someone asked me that,
both the Jewish question,
right?
And the,
the implication,
it was actually someone Jewish and the
implication was that,
um,
Jews are overrepresented in positions of
authority and power.
And,
and I was,
had just spoken for like an hour and a
half and you know,
this guy had an ax to grind.
And I thought,
there's No God damn way I'm getting into
this at the moment.
And so I,
I said,
I can't answer that question,
but that's not a very good answer.
So I wrote a blog post this week and I
said,
look,
here's the,
here's the situation.
All right,
Jews are overrepresented in positions of
power and authority,
but then let's open our eyes a little
bit,
hey,
and think for like two or three seconds
and think,
hey,
guess what?
They're also overrepresented in
positions of competence and it's not
like we have more geniuses.
We know what to do with,
and if the Jews happened to be producing
more of them,
which they are,
by the way,
then that's a pretty good thing for the
rest of us.
So let's not confuse competence with
power and authority,
even though that's a favorite trick of
the radical leftists who always failed
to make that distinction.
Well,
why does this overrepresentation occur?
Because it does it also.
There's also overrepresentation in
political movements,
including radical political movements.
Okay?
Why?
Well,
answer one Jewish conspiracy.
Okay,
that's not a very good answer.
We've had,
we've used that answer before.
All right,
but,
but do we have an alternative?
Well,
here's an alternative.
The average Ashkenazi Iq is somewhere
between one 10 in one 15 which is about
one standard deviation above the
population average.
And so what that means is that the
average Ashkenazi Slash European Jew has
an Iq that's higher than 85% of the
population.
That's a lot higher.
Now,
that doesn't make that much difference
in the middle of the distribution,
okay?
But genius is don't exist at the middle
of the distribution.
They exist at the tails of the
distribution.
And you don't need much of a move at the
mean to produce walloping differences at
the tails.
And the tails are important because a
lot of where we draw,
we draw exceptional people from the
exceptions,
right?
So here's an example.
Here's another example of the same
thing.
Most engineers are male.
Why?
Because men are more interested in
things and women are more interested in
people.
And he might say,
well that's socio cultural.
It's like,
no,
it's not.
And we know that because if you stack up
countries by their,
by their egalitarian social policies,
which you can do quite effectively.
And then you look at the
overrepresentation of men in stem
fields,
the overrepresentation increases as the
countries become more egalitarian.
So it's not socio cultural,
okay?
Now men aren't that much more interested
in things than women.
It's one standard deviation,
which is about the same difference,
by the way,
between the population norm and the
Ashkenazi Jews.
But if you're looking at the person who
the one person in 20 or the one person
in 50 who's most,
who's hyper interested in things,
and that's likely to become an engineer,
then most of them are men.
Here's another example of the same
thing.
Men are more aggressive than women.
Now you might ask how much and answered
that as best place to look at that as in
Sweden,
where the egalitarian policies of be
laid out for a long period of time.
And you can,
you can get a more direct inference
about biology.
If you took a random man and around in
woman out of the population and you had
to bet on who was more aggressive and
you bet on the man,
you'd be right 60% of the time.
So that's not that much,
right?
It's,
it's deviates from 50 50 but it's not
like 90 10 it's 60 40 okay,
so,
so what does that mean?
Well,
we got a tail problem here.
Again,
let's say that now you decide to go out
onto the extremes of aggression and you
identify the most aggressive one in 100
persons.
They're all men.
Guess who's in prison?
Those people,
that's why most of the people in prison
are men.
And so this is elementary part of the
problem in our society is that we don't
understand statistics.
We don't understand that you can have
relatively small differences at the
population level that produce walloping
consequences at the tails of the
distribution.
Okay,
so back died.
Q
one final thing to say about Iq.
The ethnic differences are difficult to
dispense with.
It's not easy to make them go away.
You can say,
well,
the tests aren't culture fair.
Well here's a test of that.
So imagine you,
you test group a with an Iq test and you
test group B with an Iq test and then
you look at their actual performance in
whatever you're predicting.
If the test was biased against ethnic
group A,
then it would under predict their
performance.
And that doesn't happen.
Now you could say,
well,
there's systemic bias in the performance
measures and the potential measures,
and that's a possibility.
All right?
Now one other thing about that,
there's a real danger in the ethnicity
Iq debate and the,
the danger is that we confuse
intelligence with value or that we
include,
we we confuse intelligence with yet with
human value.
That's a better way of thinking about
it.
And one of the things that we're going
to have to understand here is that
that's a mistake,
is that being more intelligent doesn't
make you a better person.
That's not the case.
It makes me you more useful for complex
cognitive operations,
but you can be pretty damn horrific as a
genius son of a bitch,
right?
It's morally neutral.
And we also know that from the
psychometric data,
by the way,
there doesn't seem to be any
relationship whatsoever between
intelligence and virtue.
And so if it does turn out that nature
and the fates do not align with our
eagle attarian presuppositions,
which is highly probable,
we shouldn't therefore make the mistake
of assuming that if group A or person a
is lower on one of these attributes than
group B or person b,
that that is somehow reflective of their
intrinsic value as human beings.
That's a big mistake.